so I'm a little obsessed with meta
things like this ridiculously massive
ship whose sole job is to ship ships
that ship things. Or this wonderful Venn
diagram of Venn diagrams. And for my
fellow geography enthusiasts we have an
island in a lake which is on an island
within a bigger lake. Wonderful.
basically something is meta when it is
self-referential and leads to another
layer abstraction, like if you're
thinking about what I'm saying right now
and then I start thinking about what
you're thinking about what I'm saying
and then you start thinking about me
thinking about what you think about what
I'm saying and then I start thinking
about that and I just want to give up on
this video honestly.
anyway the meta thing that inspired this
video in the first place involves the
GPT 2 speech generator - basically it's
an AI that can be trained on written
text or essays or news articles or
whatever you want and then will produce
realistic sounding stories based upon
whatever text you fed it so for example
if it was fed a story like this: in a
shocking finding scientists discovered a
herd of unicorns living in a remote
previously unexplored valley in the
Andes Mountains... and then it'll spit out
its own continuation of the story such
as "the scientists named the population
after their distinctive horn Ovid's
unicorn. These four horned silver white
unicorns were previously unknown to
science. Perez noticed that the valley
had what appeared to be a natural
fountain surrounded by two peaks of rock
and silver snow" quite beautiful I must
say very good AI creature GPT 2 thingy
anyway there's a subcategory on reddit
called totally not robots which is a
place where people write things
pretending to be badly disguised His
like this: normal ocean animal
fertilization commencing. Neural network
engaged. Hahaha am i right
fellow humans?
But there's another subreddit which is all about taking GPT2 and training it on the text
contained in various other subreddit and
someone had the genius idea of applying
GPT to to the totally not robots
subreddit so that means that we have an
AI that imitates humans who are
pretending to be AIs that are
pretending to be humans and it's the
best thing ever
although surely if you're going to award
something as the meta champion then it
has to be this philosophy book meta
metaphysics. Metaphysics deals with all
the questions about reality that physics
can't handle so deeply existential stuff
like why is there something instead of
nothing or do numbers really exist how
do I know I'm not dreaming you know like
all those trippy unanswered questions
about the state of being and
consciousness and time and cause and
effect that keep us all up at night and
then if that wasn't enough this book
metametaphysics comes along like
something off the bookcase at the third
level of an existential crisis hell. So
it's actually asking questions about the
study of metaphysics itself questions
like: how do philosophers even reason
through metaphysical questions in the
first place? Are the answers to those
questions even determinable? and if so do those answers actually even have any
depth and meaning or is it just gonna
all sort of boil down to semantics like
the way we use words to actually
describe things as that that's what
everything hinges on? It kind of feels
like as time goes on everything is just
slowly getting more meta... from memes to humor to even like academic areas of study..
It's kind of like the second or
thermodynamics and entropy - it's almost
like metaness is a law of the universe
that can only steadily increase.
And on that note I will leave you with my
favorite example of meta humor:
a joke walks into a bar... the bartender says: WOAH! I've never met a joke before
thanks for watching folks if any of you
end up reading that metametaphysics
book then please that leave some
comments below about anything that you
find out or if there's any other
questions like this you'd like me to
delve into and of course click that
subscribe button below because well that
way I know I'm making videos that you
like